[Title Card]
Greg: Hello guys, its Greg, Gregory the Alba here.
Monette: Ah.
[ Both laugh ]
Greg: What's your name? Whats your-
Monette: Monette. I'm Monette
G: Monette
M: Not Greg
G: Not Greg
M: Sometimes
G: She likes to, you know, believe she's great as me
Um, Monette came on forever ago and, uh, I had to take the videos down
Because Ryan crossed the line a little too much
M: little, little bit.
G:Just a little too much. Um, it happens.
M: But i'm back
G: Yeah, she's back, Uh, ready to forgive me
and, Uh, to move forward in life
And I thought alright since Monette's back, we're gonna start off with
This came out a while ago, Um,
you have not played Street Fighter, right?
M: No.
G: Okay.
I'm gonna tell you who RackaRacka is real fast.
M: Okay.
G: They're a sketch comedy channel
M: Cool.
G: And they tend to do sketches
that can sometimes turn out a little dark and violent.
M: Oh.
G: Yeah.
M: Okay.
G: And I thought, Hey
what a great way to make a new first impression on the channel
M: Kind of lighten the mood here.
G: Yeah.
M: Is with violence
G: She does yoga.
Incredibly good at it.
M: Thank You.
G: One, two, tres
G: That's Street Fighter.
M: That. The whole game
G:Yeah
M: Got it.
Oh.
G: Ouch.